in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Anthony
and melody are here live and in person
welcome you guys how are ya they're
doing great Dave thank you it's an honor
to have you where do you guys live San
Antonio Texas very cool well it's really
good to have you here
so I'm guessing you're here to do your
debt-free scream yes sir yeah how much
have you paid off we paid off a $12,000
in about 10 and half months way to go
very cool making what kind of money
during that time 36,000 and then we
bumped it up to 66,000 whoa yeah
actually a month later after we paid off
our debt our income increase we both got
raises he got his first teaching job and
I just got a raise at work and it was
just a total god thing it was just kind
of funny I was like it was after you got
out of that yes yes sir
boom I'm a month later the blessings
just pour on you yes it's like God's
looking down going okay those two got
their act together time to bless him yes
very cool I love it well congratulations
so what happened at the beginning of
that ten and a half months to cause you
to want to get out of debt tell me about
your story well I had I had listened to
you about on the radio and I started
dating melody introduced you and it was
one day we're after we were married we
were we were home I had read your book
and I was just bored and so I popped in
you're dumping debt DVD and melody
joined in and after watching that she
got inspired and jumped on board yeah I
watched the DVD I I liked what Jon Acuff
said in his book to coincidentally be
watching the DVD with your friends so he
was doing that and it got me pumped and
I immediately read the book in that
weekend in three days and I said Monday
we're starting this whoa yeah just like
that yep boom and how long have you been
married um it'll be tears in me okay
very cool so you were married at that
point then yes it was about six months
into our marriage okay very cool so what
kind of debt was the twelve thousand it
was all my school debt he had already
paid his debt in his car before we were
married and it was my school debt I was
kind of one of those stubborn seniors
who was adamant about going to a
four-year university instead of
Community College
mm-hmm and yeah it's got $10,000 in debt
mm-hmm and what's your degree in
journalism communication but for you
okay very good
cool how does it feel it feels good and
I we were taking this trip it just feels
good that we don't know anybody any
money just like you talking about the
grass feels a little different the car
drives a little different mm-hmm and we
actually have that peace you know when
we go to bed not you know nobody's at
our door you know very cool
so are you guys rent or do you own your
home we're renting right now we actually
had some questions we were already
starting to kind of save for a house um
we found out we were pregnant thank you
and so we are just kind of in that limbo
of you know we're still saving obviously
I'm almost done with our emergency fund
mm-hmm and just piling on after that and
just kind of waiting to see if we use it
for the baby and then you're gonna make
the decision after that probably we'll
wait another year for anything that's
about right yeah just get the baby home
and everybody's good and solid and get
that behind you and then you don't want
to move and have a baby in the same
short period of time that's just
nightmarish I mean that'd be unless
somebody's making you move you know so
yeah you're doing great
well congratulations you guys your
income shot way up the family's on the
way life is good
things are happening for you I'm so
proud for you I'm proud of you excellent
job so what do you tell people the
secret to getting out of debt is for me
getting on the budget and getting over
yourself as well you know you get that
new job or you just graduate like oh I
deserve this and I deserve that I ironed
it well not just like you say if if you
don't have cash to pay for it you
haven't earned it yet and for me it was
unity I wouldn't make fun of him I would
call him cheap a lot before we were
married and I would just it's so mad
when we you know we wouldn't go places I
wanted to go and I stopped doing that
you know I instead of you know making
fun of him I joined them and I we became
United and I think that's really what
just helped us what cost you to do that
I think conviction for me and just
knowing that it was you base everything
on God's Word that was just so powerful
in my life
mm-hmm well I can I ask I mean I
wondered if when you were saying that if
the reason you did that was you suddenly
saw that if I joined in his way it was
living like no one else so that later
we can live and give like no one else
and you saw a goal that worked maybe and
is that did that happen melody yeah
definitely I mean before that I never
knew that I could save that much or do
something like that I was never you know
I just never made that kind of money I
would make the money and spend it kind
of thing and so me being able to do that
you know pay off $10,000 was a big deal
to me coming out of college and so now
that that we've done that it was it's so
much easier now we've saved you know
almost all of our emergency fund which
is almost that much and it's just it
seems so much easier I'm just like wow I
can do this we can save a down payment
for a house you know and what you said
Anthony is really powerful in the sense
that we all feel like we quote/unquote
deserve something get over yourself
okay that was a great phrase I like that
when you get over yourself you can get
out of that that's a that's the truth
that really was is what it comes down to
for a lot of folks to get this under
control well congratulations you two
and congratulations on the baby on the
way life is good very cool Anthony and
melody San Antonio Texas
$12,000 paid off their debt free and ten
and a half months they were making 36
until they got out of debt now they're
making 66 that's the way that happens
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three two one
well done you guys very very well done
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]